hey 42 here we think of wars as
relatively uncommon but that couldn't be
further from the truth since the end of
the Second World War there have been
over 250 major Wars worldwide
thus equates to almost four wars per
year but war isn't a new problem
invented by the stresses and tensions of
modern-day life over the past three
thousand four hundred years humans have
only been at peace entirely without war
for 268 of them to put that into
perspective humans have only been at
peace with one another for eight percent
of recorded history all this fighting
doesn't come without a heavy price tag
Wars are ridiculously costly both in
cold hard cash and human lies but what
is that price tag let's find out the
real cost of a war once and for all
first let's try and work out the cost of
water ugliest side-effects human lives
every war has a different cost so for
the purpose of illustration let's
examine a recent well-documented war the
Iraq and Afghanistan war on terror along
large scale and horrendously expensive
war that began in 2001 following the
9/11 attacks which to some extent still
goes on to this day
the number of estimated deaths of the
Iraq Afghanistan war between 2001 and
2014 are as follows US and Allied troops
thirty eight thousand seven hundred and
thirty three journalists three hundred
and forty-four humanitarian workers 438
opposition forces eighty eight thousand
and twenty four and finally civilians
two hundred and twenty thousand yeah
that's right in most Wars the majority
of casualties are not from the armies
themselves but civilians and those
numbers are only the deaths caused
directly by conflict they don't include
the thousands of over indirect deaths
caused by the side effects of war such
as disease and famine the majority of
civilian casualties during the Iraq
Afghanistan war were caused by
anti-personnel and anti-tank mines as
well as ground attacks from insurgents
there's no denying that the human cost
of war is immeasurably horrific so let's
take a look at the second facet of
wartime expense the monetary cost how
much money do you really need to go to
war with another country
again the answer entirely depends on the
scale and the nature of the war so let's
once again use the Iraq Afghanistan war
as an example why because it was the
most expensive war of the past 50 years
it is estimated that by the time it's
over the Iraq Afghanistan war will cost
a whopping six trillion US dollars to
put that into perspective six trillion
dollars is enough money to feed every
single starving person on earth for 200
is just to clarify with that money you
could feed a billion starving people
every year for the next 200 years but
it's not quite as simple as just sending
all that money to Africa the majority of
the money the u.s. used to pay for the
war was actually borrowed mostly from
China the George Bush administration
estimated it would cost between 50 and
60 billion dollars to invade Iraq and
overthrow Saddam Hussein that's
considerably less than the total running
cost us of today so what went wrong what
have all those six trillion dollars of
taxpayers and borrowed money spent on
well the fingers they haven't actually
been spent yet to date the US has spent
one point six trillion dollars towards
the wars in Iraq and Afghanistan that
includes everything from military
equipment firearms training wages and
hiring third-party contractors among
governs it's estimated that the cost of
keeping a single American soldier in
Iraq or Afghanistan for a year is three
point nine million dollars so where does
the over estimated four point four
trillion dollars come in well that comes
later the biggest cost of a war is not
the war itself it's the aftermath
especially when you borrow most of them
when you used to pay for the war the
majority of the money used to pay for
the Iraq Afghanistan war was borrowed
and there's a big load of interest to
pay on top of it the interest is so
great in fact that over the next few
years the repayments will tally up to
several trillions of dollars but there's
an even bigger long-term cost veteran
care and benefits nine hundred and
seventy thousand veterans of the Iraq
and Afghanistan wars have registered for
disability claims over the course of the
next 50 years payments for the care and
welfare of all those veterans will bring
the total cost of the war up to an
estimated six trillion dollars but for
every soldier who fights in the war
sadly for them the war never ends in
2012 more veterans of the Iraq and
Afghanistan wars committed suicide than
were actually killed in action this
isn't a new problem most veterans of the
nine
1882 Falklands War have committed
suicide since the war than died in
combat war has many evil facets and
whether it's a medieval battle or a
modern-day hi-tech skirmish you can
always count on two things the effects
will be catastrophic and the costs will
be outrageously high but Wars don't have
to be expensive in 1920 the British
forces defeated the Dervish forces of
Mohammed Abdullah Hassan he was more
commonly referred to as mad mullah
amongst opposition forces Britain's
resistance against a 20 year-old dervish
forces was known as the Somaliland
campaign it came to a climax during the
fifth and final war of the campaign in
1920 when the British Royal Air Force
accompanied by Britain's Somaliland
Camel corpse yes that was actually a
thing defeated the dervishes strongholds
in what was then known as British
Somaliland this war has gone down in
history as the cheapest war in history
costing a grand total of just 77
thousand pounds which is about 3.5
million pounds by today's standards that
sounds expensive but it's actually
really bloody cheap most Wars cost in
the region of several billions to
several trillion if most wars are so
expensive and caused nothing but turmoil
and sorrow then why do we have them in
the first place it's widely debated that
Wars don't actually solve any problems
after all we have only been without war
for 8% of recorded history if war solved
problems wouldn't that mean war would
become less frequent when in reality the
opposite is happening with 250 wars in
the past 70 years it seems that Wars
only creates more problems and
subsequently more wars many people
believe was off strictly for profit yes
wars are costly but they also put money
into many pockets namely arms and
military vehicle manufacturers when the
cost is human lives it's saddening to
think that some people are profiting
from it
it truly is a sickening fault but
whether profits is actually the main
contributing factor to starting a war is
still a topic of much debate and
controversy every war is different
sometimes it's driven by profit and
other times it's just the perverted
fantasies and disillusions of a doomed
soul thanks for the view subscribe for
more thoughty2 as a combat veteran i
know the cost of war
tulsi gabbard here are the 25 most
expensive wars in history 25 war on
terror including the wars in Iraq and
Afghanistan this fight has cost the
nation's involved a significant amount